we begin with this the star witness and
Paul manna for its fraud trial will
testify again this morning after telling
jurors he and mana fort broke the law
together
Rick gates a former deputy chairman of
the Trump campaign became its first
senior official to admit criminal
activity while under oath gates also
testified that he stole money from mana
Ford who served for a time it's a Trump
campaign chairman Paula Reid is outside
the courthouse in Alexandria Virginia
Paula good morning good morning this
trial the first big public test for the
special counsel has nothing to do with
President Trump or his campaign but
investigators uncovered evidence of
possible crimes while investigating
Russian meddling in the 2016 campaign
and some of the alleged bank fraud
occurred while mana fort was chairman of
the Trump campaign Paul Manafort stared
down his former colleague as he took the
stand but Gates looked directly at
Special Counsel prosecutor Greg Andres
as he asked gates did you commit crimes
as Mr Man afford yes
gates replied the special counsels
Office charged gates and mana fort with
dozens of crimes related to their
lobbying efforts on behalf of foreign
governments but gates agreed to flip on
his former boss in exchange for leniency
pleading guilty to conspiracy against
the United States and making a false
statement to the Special Counsel office
on the stand gates admitted that at men
affords direction he falsified tax
returns hid millions of dollars from
Ukrainian operatives failed to report
foreign bank accounts and failed to
register man afford as a foreign agent
Gates also admitted that while he helped
mana Ford commit these crimes he also
embezzled from him I added money to
expense reports and created expense
reports that were not accurate he said
to pad his salary by several hundred
thousand dollars despite is damaging
testimony gates also complimented his
former boss saying that mana Ford is
probably one of the most politically
brilliant strategists I've ever worked
with
Paul Manafort has done an amazing job
during the campaign President Trump also
praised Manta Ford and his team for
their strategy all of Paul's people Paul
brought on staff and we really do we
have a great staff of talented people
but following the indictments the Trump
administration consistently downplayed
mana forts role Matta Ford has nothing
to do with our campaign but I feel so I
tell you I feel a little badly about it
they went back 12 years to get things
that he did 12 years ago you know pull
mana for it worked for me for a very
short period of time
prosecutors have at least three more
hours worth of questions for gates and
then defense attorneys will get a crack
at him mana Ford's whole defense is that
he put his trust in gates who then
embezzled from him and failed to
accurately report their business income
to the government Vlad
alright Paulo Reed will be watching
thank you